i'm very pleased to say that the
transport secretary grant shaps joins us
once again
on the programme good to see you this
morning mr shaps a busy few days
ahead for you and indeed for your team
um so let's start with with the borders
this morning shall we we heard from the
health secretary a list of new measures
to to toughen up
uh at the borders to the united kingdom
can you just run us through them but but
also
just explain exactly why we are we are
doing this at this point in time
yeah i guess the first things to say is
it's not about the prevalence of the
virus elsewhere now it's about the
variance
and that's the thing that we're tracking
that's why we're taking a slightly
different approach but these are
additional things that we're doing on
top of things like
pre-departure testing that was already
required before you
travel here from somewhere else and a
passenger locator form that you have to
fill in by law and you can be thrown off
the flight if you if you don't have in
fact you won't get onto the flight if
you don't have it
but now in addition to that when you get
back here you must
quarantine again that's been in place
but also
take mandatory tests on day two and day
eight
uh and in addition to that there are a
set of countries we call them the red
list countries
33 of them at the moment where we're
saying um there should be
in fact there are no direct flights
whatsoever from those countries that
haven't been for a while again
but if you are traveling via another
route from those countries
then you must quarantine in a hotel and
so that's being introduced as well
from monday just in terms of of the
hotel rollouts of course clearly there
have
been some concerns some questions about
how many rooms we have available
how many rooms in fact we will need to
maintain the system moving forward
i mean can you can you give us that
detail come monday how many i've got
as of now how many have we got how many
will we have by monday and and how many
do we need given you know
people are going to be staying in that
hotel room not for a handful of days but
for
you know a week and a half sure well
first of all there are over
000 hotel rooms uh these are sort of if
you like government managed
facili facilities these hotels there are
5 000 immediately available
uh and bear in mind these are from
countries where there are no direct
flights at all
a majority of brits will have already
returned from those locations
and very very few people are traveling
at all at this stage
um 16 to 20 000 a day and that includes
the hauliers who
who bring our goods uh to this country
and other categories like
border workers so we're down to a very
very small number of people
uh and we can just increase those
numbers very quickly in a day or so
uh because we've got those agreements in
place can you then just
tell us a little bit more about those
those agreements agreements in place
five five thousand hotel rooms is a
great start clearly but with estimates
you know around about 1500 uh perhaps
visitors arriving from those redless
countries every day
it appears that by you know the middle
of next week we might be getting close
to capacity
i know i've seen some of those numbers
thrown around and and and i don't think
they're they're they're correct because
um if you think about the very small
number of people who are traveling at
the moment i mean travel is 95
down on uh where it was this time uh
last year
and of the remaining people who travel
once you strip out the lorry drivers who
are bringing our medicines and foods
here
uh frontier workers critical you know uh
people who come over to for example um
keep our
critical infrastructure uh working um
actually the number of people traveling
uh overall is very low and then beyond
that we're only talking about another
subsection of people
who are traveling here from those red
list countries uh where there are no
direct flights in any case
so we're talking about a very easy
a day and by next week when people will
have to pay to do this
1750 pounds package on top of of course
their
costs of getting here via an indirect
route i think we'll find the numbers are
actually pretty small
but as i say the way it's fine because
we can increase hotel numbers very very
quickly we've got those agreements in
place
how do we as a number of colleagues of
yours on on conservative benches are
asking
how do we get out of this what is the
the the
the bar that we need to surpass to start
drawing down on these on these travel
restrictions
yeah i mean look i'm transport secretary
so i absolutely
want people to be able to travel but it
is a fact that right now
it's illegal to leave your home to go on
holiday it's illegal to do that in the
uk
or um or around the world so i'm afraid
at the moment that's that's off the
cards
having said that um fortunately i think
the the total number of
vaccinations injected now is 13.1
million overall
uh in this country which i just checked
actually is more than all of the eu put
together
in terms of the number of people being
vaccinated so far so we're we're getting
great guns on that and we're moving very
fast
that's a very very important part of how
we get to unlock the situation
and the prime minister will make a
statement about this and say more about
it on the 22nd
when he'll be able to set out a sort of
route to unlock um
very similar to what happened last year
but of course now this time
not just with the benefit of seeing the
reductions through the lockdown but also
the reductions through
vaccine and i should also say through
the massive testing
program that's now in place that's
enabled us to surge the testing in
certain areas where we've seen these
variants as well
so we've got a lot more sort of tools in
our armory now
i can't give you an exact date at this
stage the prime minister will say more
and then we'll have a
a series of dates during which we will
be able to gradually
unlock things if we see cases continue
to reduce and
and and deaths as well forgive me if
i'm if i'm wrong here but it does feel
that you seem rather more confident
about us getting
some form of summer holiday than than
perhaps even the health secretary i mean
yesterday
it did rather feel that he was linking
as coming out of this
significant action on our borders to you
know a booster vaccine come the autumn
that might provide that additional
protection against the variants that
let's not forget are already in the
country despite the action that we're
taking right now
yeah look and i don't want to kind of
unnecessarily raise people's hopes
the truth is we just don't know how the
virus will
respond and both to the vaccines and of
course how people will respond and
therefore
to the social distancing and those kind
of measures and therefore exactly
when we'll be able to unlock so i'm
afraid i can't give you a definitive
will there or will there not be the
opportunity to take holidays this next
year either at home or abroad
but what i do know is right now thanks
to
people adhering to the the lockdown and
thanks to the enormous vaccination
program it's just been
extraordinary as i say more more than
the whole of the rest of the you put
together
in terms of injections thanks to those
two things
we are starting to see those reductions
but i don't know what the situation will
be uh by the middle of the
summer uh nobody can tell from the point
that we we sit right now
and so i'm afraid it is sitting tight
observing the rules
uh and waiting for if you haven't had
your injection yet uh depending on the
category you're in waiting for that call
unless you're
over 70 in which case please do contact
uh your gp
or go to nhs uh website if this is
toughening up at the borders was as you
say
to to do with you know dealing with
variants of the virus
variants which like the south african
virus south african variant
may have you know some form of
resistance to the vaccines that we have
on stream at the moment haven't we
somewhat missed the boat why is it
taking us so long
to get to a point where we are testing
people arriving in this country
after they get into the country so first
of all it's really important
often misunderstood mutations the virus
take place
all the time and they've been thousands
of mutations of this virus most
are uh don't change um things that
they're almost like passengers within
the virus
they come and go throughout this uh
coronavirus there'd been many a time um
where
uh the the level the prevalence the
amount of virus elsewhere
um has been lower uh than it has been
here and in which case
it hasn't really uh much mattered in
fact some some would
say some have argued um that if it's
lower elsewhere then there's no real
concern about people being outside of
the country simply for the fact that
you have more chance of catching it in
the country if our rates were high
what we're facing now is a different
issue what we're facing now isn't about
the prevalence it's about the variance
and that is essential uh it's essential
that we
don't allow the african variant is
already there yes my point again was
why is it taking us so long to get to
this it's 12 months since we had the
first you know death recorded from
covid19 plenty of other countries have
beaten us to the punch particularly on
testing not before the border but at or
after the border
why has it taken us so long to catch up
with them the
the number one thing you can do is
quarantine or or self-isolate and of
course we've had that in place since
last spring so we we've had that in
place a lot longer than most countries
uh we've actually now got a whole suite
of different things because of these
variants which make it uh you know
amongst the
the toughest in the world is up there
with the way that south uh
korea and countries who um have
traditionally
uh had a a much more interventionist
approach to
uh these sort of uh these sort of issues
in southeast asia where they've
tackled um viruses in the past and these
pandemic
outbreaks but um the reality is
a test as i've explained many times
before is good and interesting but not
as as in terms of tackling the
uh the virus not as good as just
quarantining on its on its own so if you
were going to do one
why have we already only introduced
hotel quadrantine then
it's been going in australia new zealand
since march of last year okay
straightforward question when did the
department for transport
begin working on the policy of hotel
quarantine yeah so hold on let me just
answer your last question and this one
as well
in terms of testing capacity you'll
recall right at the beginning of this
crisis we simply didn't have the
capacity to be
testing everyone in every situation we
started off with less than two thousand
tests a day
now we've probably got eight or nine
hundred thousand available um
per day so that's a very good reason the
other thing about for example is
australia which is an example i always
hear quoted australia is an entire
continent they are pretty
self-sufficient in many different ways
the uk which for example through the
short straights that connection between
calais and dover imports 75
of its medicines uh 45 percent of our
food
we we can't operate without those said
no one has ever suggested as far as i'm
aware that we stop you know holiers
bringing medicines to the united kingdom
what plenty people have suggested is
that perhaps we're a little late to the
late to sorting out you know people
arriving in the united kingdom
from red countries which are now on the
red list i mean it has always been
described by the government the the
additional action
which has long been trailed the
additional action at our borders was all
about toughening up an already robust
set of circumstances
yeah but i mean just look at the the the
way in which it is being enforced
you know up until this point we've
relied largely on civil penalties
and people doing their duty it is not a
chain it is not a
toughening up of that to say you could
end up in jail for 10 years that's an
entirely new policy
okay so so look first of all um people
have been being checked border force
have checked 3.7
million uh uh um passenger locator forms
as they've come in and more recently of
course with the pre-departure testing
they've checked those as well um so it's
not that i
i keep hearing people haven't been
checked that's not true however you are
right to say
um that because the variance is a at a
whole different
scale to just how prevalent the
diseases i mentioned before there were
many times during this in fact
the entire travel corridor policy was on
the basis that where you were traveling
to
had to by definition have lower levels
of coronavirus than here
so that that was a different issue what
we're dealing with now is the variance
and with variance
we cannot risk it in these final stages
where we've got the vaccine roll
rolled out that we might end up with uh
difficulty from
from variations although we think so far
that we'll be able to take care of them
through
the vaccines and because of that we
think it's appropriate that
things like prison sentences for lying
about being in one of those red list
countries
are appropriate and look i just don't
agree with the idea that we somehow
didn't act quickly i can tell you within
six hours of finding out of one of these
variants this is the mink variant in
denmark
we changed the law possibly a record
time for changing the law in this
country so there'd be many occasions
where we've had to act extremely well
i mean we could mention you know the
kind of the count variant when it hit
london and people have been telling you
to kind of act on that you know a
fortnight before you did but i i do want
to conclude
sorry let me just let me just pick you
up on that because because that's how
these stories get out there that are
wrong
the variants occur and we may get a clue
about them but as i said
we see a lot of different mutations
taken thousands of mutations
what you have to then do is genome
sequence them and that is a process i'm
talking about
some action and the government decided
not to do it for a fortnight that was
the point that i've no no no no no no no
no
no
i do i do want to conclude minnesota
fair enough i do want to conclude
minister um there's going to be five
billion
pounds worth of grants and loans today
to get rid of cladding on on buildings
and of course you you have a good degree
of experience of working in housing
steven mcpartland your colleague says
because you know a building's under 18
meters
people will be having to take out loans
he describes it
uh millions of leaseholders are facing
financial ruin and will not accept loans
they are not a solution
they are a disgraceful betrayal i just
wonder your thoughts on that
well first of all i mean uh this
cladding situation has been you know
we've all seen the the impact of it and
it's been absolutely horrendous
the government's already uh put in 1.6
billion
pounds to uh trying to get the cladding
removed i know that the
uh housing secretary of state will be
saying more this lunch time and he's
got a statement in the house and we'll
have to wait for um for that
um but there's a a fairly complicated
picture because you have
lease holders uh but you also have um
sort of joint ownerships uh you
sometimes have council ownerships and i
know that
uh robert generic the housing secretary
wants to get to the bottom of trying to
help everybody
uh so that people are not out of pocket
i'm probably we'll have to wait till
later
uh to see exactly what he says and how
much money is involved but i think it's
a good thing the government is standing
behind
people in that position